the generic system for humans seems to
be a form of polygamy that's the almost
the default
um
uh why would you have
a kind of this kind of romantic
component to it this this very strong
pair bond because you get that
in polygamous marriages you know that's
what happens
um
when when a new wife is taken on you
know um it's not because
well sometimes it's because the the the
first wife who is always becomes the
chief wife says you're boring go and
find another little one
to play with
um i mean literally that that you know
is the kind of thing that happens or
um the the husband actually falls in
love with somebody else and wants to
bring bring this new wife younger always
always younger into
um the household
and then it's a trade-off for the
first wife or if this is the third wife
of the first two wives
as to whether they're happy with that
arrangement or whether they just shrug
their shoulders and go
we can live our lives quite happily
without uh
having to be bothered by the the husband
as it were
um so
it's still a mystery in that sense so
the question then is you know what's
underpinned the evolution of this kind
of
romantic falling in love component
so the classic answer has always been
well it must be
the need for by parental care human
babies are
born absolutely premature by a whole
year
um that's why they're all kind of floppy
and useless and you know
don't even smile at you never mind
be you know behave in a an engagingly
human way you need something
uh
to to to
sort of persuade you to keep investing
in it until it's
uh have completed its growth that all
other monk monkey snapes do before birth
um and starts to if you like become more
seriously human
and it that is so taxing
for the mother that having
somebody else around why not the male
to help out is um absolutely necessary
and you kind of go well that sounds
awfully like american culture to me not
real life
um you know where in the world does that
actually happen and the answer is well
as you know sometimes the non-together
societies you know the men daniel babies
on their knees and do things like that
just as all men everywhere do
um
change your nappy here and there but
they're not really that good at um
helping out you know they're much better
when
when the kids are
old enough to you know fire a bow and
arrow and learn how to do these kind of
useful tasks
so i deeply suspect the amount of
paternal care that humans give despite
desperate efforts to
uh claim that it's
part of our
uh nature uh simply isn't the reason at
all um
uh and and that's because in the end the
people who are most valuable to the
mother
in almost all societies and just as much
in ours as anybody else is
is
the grandmother
and the sisters
and maybe
your female best friend
that these are the ones that really make
the the business of particularly those
early years
um uh
possible if you're like less
trouble-free than they might be do on
your own
and and you know sort of yes males are
useful um
if they're
own land that you can you can farm and
produce you know lots of crops to feed
your
children on and all those kind of things
and we know that's important we know
from
um historical demography data for
example um from europe that in in the
18th and 19th centuries that
women whose husbands were
landed peasantries so they only had a
few acres
you know they weren't the nobility they
weren't even middle class they were
peasants
you know a bit like crop crofters you
might say in in scotland you know
they've got
five
acres of land or something like that and
they can grow a few the more land
uh the husband had
the better the survival chances of of
the wife's children
were and of course you know for landless
peasants who day laborers that they
the only
way they could earn a living was to hire
themselves out by the day to to help
with
other people's farms you know their
wives you know had high mortality rates
because
when they needed to go to the doctor
they didn't have the odd fiver
to spare for the doctor's fee they you
know uh if if they couldn't it didn't
have any money they couldn't buy any
food all these kind of things piling in
on them the same old story
that we we even now you know still have
to cope with
um so
you know yes once you have agriculture
once you have wealth uh accumulating
then then the males can contribute
indirectly
but that comes late you know that
doesn't happen until 8 000 years ago
with the neolithic agricultural
revolution prior to that for
several million years
or lineage um you know just hunter
gatherers so
those kind of issues don't necessarily
um come uh work out and you know in
typically anyway you might say well
maybe um a husband who's a particularly
good hunter is the equivalent thing and
the answer is
not really
in hunter-gatherer societies because if
he's a good hunter and he can bring down
mammoths
instead of you know a chicken
always in those societies those big um
prey
uh that are hunted are shared
with the whole
camp it's only small things
um that you eat within the family of the
hunter on their own so you know
it seems to me there really isn't all
that much evidence to support the claim
that
uh this romantic relationship is there
for
um
uh by parental care as such as as the
technical term is
and the the only obvious answer uh seems
to be
this is a hard gun problem
right so what it in effect it is
happening
is that the females are wanting to
attach themselves to a particular male
essentially for protection what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]